[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man in this video
we're going to be breaking down every
single Spider-Man and woman appearing in
across the spider verse what film is
gonna be packed with hundreds of
variants and we've compiled the posters
trailers and also what we know about the
film to talk about them all been a big
job and first off I want to go through
the recently released trailer as that
contains almost all of the main ones
we'll then shift over to the giant
poster and discuss the ones in that
before sitting down and having a pint
because sake there's a lot going on
anyway first Spider-Man is Miles Morales
that's it let's pack it up and go home
no now miles was first introduced in the
Ultimate Spider-Man comics and similar
to what we've seen into the spider-verse
his version of Peter died the
designation for this Earth is earth1610
but they haven't ever confirmed the one
that we following into the spider-verse
however we do know that our next
character Gwen comes from Earth 65
spider Gwen's Peter was killed yeah and
this very much became her Uncle Ben
moment as I'm sure you can guess Gwen
didn't die in this timeline and neither
did her father who will be appearing in
the film now the latest trailer has his
necks meeting Spider Woman Who will be
she is heavily pregnant and a design is
different to the way that she looks in
the comics whether this Spider Woman
does appear later on in the trailer or
when we see all the characters riding on
top of a train anyway next we see
Herbert Brown and we know that he's
going to be voiced by Daniel caluya
going under the name spider Punk he's
very much riffing on spider UK except
for this guy has a guitar and a metal
Mohawk next we see Spider-Man India and
he protects the city of Mumbai given his
powers by an ancient Yogi he refused to
stop at mugging one day and this led to
his uncle intervening he was killed
during this and after being racked with
Guild he decided to use his powers
solely for good now from here we travel
to the lobby which is a Nexus point in
space that all the Spider-Man can be not
to all for this [__] anyway behind Gwen
and Miles we catch a fatter red and
black Spider-Man and this may be the
version from superior Spider-Man in
which Doctor Octopus became him he might
swapped himself into Peter's body and
slowly his goodness started to change
Otto's mind however he doesn't have the
four mechanical arms at the wonders in
the comics so it might not be him and
that might just be a reach next to that
with a blue glow coming out of his chest
we have what I believe is the velocity
suit right beside that is a more shinier
classic suit and it is possible that
this is a variation of Spider-Man at the
end of no way home I also think that the
spider armor MK4 is in there too and
this is what Peter wore when he became
the CEO of pocket Industries now those
ones at the back are kind of difficult
to make out so we'll move forward to the
ledge where we get the next set the
first one on the left is Spider-Girl and
this is actually an older Mayday Parker
who appears later on in the teaser she
first showed up in what if 105 and was
Peter and Mary Jane's daughter who taken
over the mantle walking behind her we
get another female's Spider-Man who
looks like she's wearing the black and
white feature foundation suit this 2011
Burke had Peter becoming a member of the
team with the Fantastic Four and though
this is a woman in the costume it does
look identical now that's a suit that
you might recognize from the PS4 game
alongside the Mark II armor that appears
right next to it his bulletproof costume
was done by Peter when he lost his
Spider Sense and this allowed him to
protect himself when heading into
gunfights now he looked far and wide for
this next suit and according to Games
Radar this is the anti-king PIN one it
apparently first appeared in The Amazing
Spider-Man 62 and if they found it and I
didn't then that means they're better
than me now from here we get the PS4
suit and then we get what looks like it
may be the superior Spider-Man suit as
well lots of duplicates in here as well
so apologies if I repeat stuff but I'm
just being thorough anyway we pull out
even further and in the top left we can
catch the manga vs Spider-Man talked
about him a lot in our breakdown of the
trailer but his Sensei Ben was killed by
Venom and he ended up donning the
costume later on we see him riding on on
top of the train as well and you can
catch him in the bottom right as it
races forward now in front of him is a
clearer view of spider pig now this is
spider cop sorry if you're a policeman
watching this and he first appeared in
spider getting 4 back in 2018 protecting
New York as a member of the NYPD he was
recruited by spider Gwen to join the
team in the spider-verse storyline
anyway right beside him is an all red
suit which looks like the Rubber One
Peter War whilst battling Electro to the
right of him we can catch spinneret and
this is a variant of Mary Jane she and
Peter had a daughter together and you
can actually catch her standing right
behind her this is spiderling and I'm
pretty sure that the pair both appeared
together in the renew of our storyline
now the steampunk looking Spider Woman
is called lady spider and he comes from
an earth set in the 1800s named May
Riley she takes the full name of Aunt
May and has these mechanical spider legs
that we see sticking out of her back not
100 sure on who the next one is as he
seems to be like a generic variant but
let me know below if you know who this
one is now walking above the pair we can
catch a shirtless Spider-Man who seems
like he's only wearing a mask Underpants
and Boots this may be the undies
Spider-Man and you might remember him as
appearing in the PS4 game as an
unlockable skin right in front of spider
cop yours that have a red and gold suit
and this is the one that Peter wore in
the Civil War storyline next we have a
group of spider peeps turning together
and the guy with a big blue chest is
spider side a leftover from the 90s
clone saga he first appeared in The
Amazing Spider-Man 399 and next to him
is a red spider woman and it's possible
that this is actually ultimate
Spider-Woman from the Ultimate Universe
next we pull out to see Captain spider
and this is what we would get if Flash
Thompson got the powers instead like
many of these he comes from a what if
storyline and the character debuted back
in 1977 now walking in front of him is
the bombastic Bag Man in the comics
Peter went to the Baxter building to
remove the symbiote suit but in the end
this left him without any clothes does
he took a Fantastic Four uniform and he
also took a brown bag to wear over his
face lastly in the top right we can
catch spider wolf who debuted back in
The Amazing Spider-Man 11 from 2014.
whew anyway next we cut to Spider-Man
2099 AKA magello horror coming from the
futuristic Nueva York he's the leader of
this pack of Misfits after creating a
bracelet that could stabilize
multiversal travel next we get Peter
Parker and according to the wiki this
isn't coming from me he's actually
coming from Earth 616. it is getting
hella confusing because the comet
universe is 616 the MCU is meant to be
that as well and we now have Peter B
who's apparently from there too why
don't you explain this to me like I'm
five anyway moving on WE next cut the
more shots of the lobby and to the left
we get a red and white suit this looks
like it might be based on the white 2099
suit though it's far less bulky and
probably not that what a waste of time
anyway beside that we have the armor
Mark II which is a white suit that
appeared in the comics and also the 90s
cartoon soon a lot of these do kind of
just seem generic but to the right of
that we can catch the back of the Mark
III armor burst appearing in The Amazing
Spider-Man 682 this was designed to
bring down every member of the Sinister
Six it could pick up on the chameleon's
heartbeat and was also electro-proof for
fights against him we can also see at
the back that there's a Spider-Man with
a big throw standing to the right of
Spider Woman due to his guitar that we
see later on the trailer I'm guessing
that this is spider Punk with his mask
off anyway the next major shot is on top
of the train and we have a giant
Spider-Man to the left who could be
ripping on giant man we also have cyborg
Spider Woman to the right and a Spider
Woman wearing a sexy Santa costume next
we cut to more Montage shot and in this
we see Scarlet Spider AKA Ben Riley from
here we see three Spider-Mans standing
together and I think that this might be
the Japanese Spider-Man on the left in
the middle is Spider-Man Unlimited from
the 90s and to the right of him is the
PS4 one lastly we cut to a big group
shot and in the top right we can catch a
Spider-Man hanging from his fingertips
like Andrew Garfield in no way home
there's also a night Spider-Man as well
I said in the breakdown that he might be
a samurai but many of you corrected me
so I look like a [__] idiot now this
takes us into the big chase shot and
there's a lot here as well this includes
spider mechanic who first showed up in
Avengers 9 is also Earth X Spider-Man
and lastly the White Widow wearing the
white suit finally we go to the
therapist room and get a more generic
Spider-Man who looks in line with PW
Parker you also have a therapist and in
the top right of Rorschach test that
looks like it's a spider it then all
burst through the wall and we can see
leading the charge is a horse with a
spider mask on it this is actually Widow
and he comes directly from the comics
now we go over to the poster and I'm
gonna try to avoid just repeating the
ones that have appeared in the video so
far however it's impossible to talk
about all this without being thorough
and we have 20.99 at the front the Mark
III armor by miles's head and Spider-Man
in the air sitting to the right to his
right we have the spectacular Spider-Man
and you might recognize him from the
animated show Josh Keaton voiced him in
the series and we know that he'll be
returning as the character for the
upcoming film now to the right of him we
have a Spider-Man with a collar and he
first appeared in the happy birthday
storyline this is an older version of
the character and they later adapted him
into is he killed Sims for his further
appearances to his left is the therapist
we see at the end and to his right is
the werewolf Spider-Man we then have
what appears to be a black suit
Spider-Man spider side lady spider and a
Gandalf looking wizard one with a Long
White Beard the black suit with the
embossed lines is also the Mark 1 armor
and this is what the character first
wore when he decided to upgrade his suit
now to the top left of Gwen's head we
can see spider bite she appears in the
trailer for a split second and she comes
from a world that's basically Ready
Player one we have spider Punk to the
right of that and then Peter B Parker
with Spider-Man Unlimited below him
Captain spider then pops up above him
and Cyborg's Spider Woman can be seen to
his top left anyway above israe's spider
a woman we have Julia carpet as Spider
Woman and she first appeared in secret
Wars up to her left we have web Slinger
and he's a wild west Spider-Man who'll
probably be seen with Widow above him
sits spider cat and this is a character
that you might know from the Spider-Man
PS4 game he also appeared in spider
Island New York City issue 1 and I'm
hoping that we see some fine [__] in
this movie I think we got away with that
one now to the top right of him faded
into the poster you also have one with
giant eyes that could potentially be
Ultimate Spider-Man in front of him we
have Scarlet Spider-Man spinnerette the
PS4 Spider-Man and the Knight to her
fall left in between her and the Knight
is the character doppelganger who's a
wild six ARM version of the character
with bangs and sharp claws to the far
far left we have Mexican Spider-Man
above him then we have what actually
looks like a samurai Spider-Man then we
have the anti-king pin suit before we go
to the bombastic bag man I'm pretty sure
that's all of them I couldn't spot an
Andrew Garfield one though it does look
like one who has his suit next stubbed
to the guy on the right with a big hat
might not be him but those eyes do look
kind of similar so I just just put
Andrew down to end the video on a high
note also I think we have spider monkey
in one of the trailers for like half a
second so yeah don't don't go writing in
the comments that we missed him because
we didn't see a chump anyway that's the
video and I hope you liked it you better
have took lots of time so uh if you if
you did enjoy it then please hit the
thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns like this
almost every day not going through this
again but if you want something else to
watch then we will have a video linked
on screen right now and without the way
I've been poor you've been the best I'll
see you next time you take care yourself
peace
[Music]